No love will tend to touch no
no they said he had a Heart of Stone till I sing
it locks and her song and cracked his heart into
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be my
video for The Witcher blood origin ending and how
it ties in with the Witcher season 3 if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos and careful for spoilers from
the series if you haven't seen it yet the big
surprises the series takes place before even
all the earliest lore in history that we know
from the books and from the video games most of
what we know goes back about a thousand years to
the first conjunction of the Spheres this took
place even before that because the conjunction
of the Spheres doesn't happen until like the
very end of the series it's basically meant
to tell you the origin of Ciri's Elder blood the
origin of the wild Hunt Eredin and the origin of
the white Frost seeming villain like the ultimate
villain of The Witcher universe but it does seem
like they change a few things and invoke a lot of
time travel to set up further stuff on like The
Witcher season four or however they're going to
end the series that's where we get into a couple
additions to the lore like there are a couple
retcons that they introduced during the series
that seemingly contradicts some of the lore that
we already know about that part of The Witcher
timeline so I'll try to explain where that fits
in and why I think think they added some of that
stuff during the series we meet the seven quote
unquote which are a group of elves that lead to
the conjunction of the Spheres the creation
of the first proto-witcher not actually the
first Witcher they call it a proto-witcher I'll
explain that in the beginning of the line that
will be the Elder blood program that eventually
culminates in Ciri during all the Witcher games
all the books you hear about ithlan's prophecies
about Ciri about the culmination of the Elder
blood and how she's going to defeat the white
frost during The Witcher blood origin they give
Italy and a couple prophecies like they say that
this is one of many prophecies she's already had
they've all come true at the very end she tells
Éile that she's going to be the beginning of the
line of Elder blood that will culminate in Ciri
she also starts talking a lot about time travel
like elves displaced in time so time travel is
going to be a big part of The Witcher TV series
there is some time travel in the books that'll
get into what's happening with avallac'hwhich
you also see in the post-credits scene as well
too we see how the Aen Elle elves went to the
other world like there are two different groups
of elves the original elves on the continent were
three different kingdoms that eventually through
coup become one Kingdom and a bunch get deposited
on this other world during the conjunction of the
Spheres one of the big additions to the lore is
that during the video games during the books we
actually thought that the other group of elves
that Eredin comes from purposefully went to the
other world like they traveled there on purpose
the way they explained this during the series
they accidentally wound up there when the worlds
merged during the conjunction of the sphere so
they didn't go there on purpose they wound up
being stranded there we also found out why the
conjunction of the Spheres happened too which I
don't believe that they totally get into during
the books the first conjunction was a result of
chaos magic interacting with the destruction of
the monoliths like the model is amplifying the
power of chaos magic tearing the veil Between
Worlds between dimensions that's what stranded
everybody on different worlds that's how humans
came to the main world how monsters came to the
main World in how Eredin and some of the elves
wound up on that other arid world but one of
the big things that they introduced earlier in
The Witcher season two there's a big flashback
the Ciri has where she sees her ancestor Laura
Doran one of the things they did during the series
is they introduced the Éile character who says
that she is the first to the line who predates
Lorra Dorren meaning that Lorra Dorren would have
to be her descendant so during series flashback
she sees Lorra Dorren she's supposed to be the
daughter of Auberon who is the king that Eredin
is serving when he creates the wild Hunt so what
might be happening in the series is they're just
saying that what we see here predates Oberon
eventually he comes along in this other world
Eredin manipulates him he becomes king of
the elves that are stuck on this other world
eventually Lorra Dorren is born and in the Canon
of the books in the video games Lorra Dorren is
the beginning of the line of the Elder blood they
start a program that's going to create a member
of their Elven race that's so powerful full of
so much magic that they'll be able to defeat the
white Frost but because the way they invoke chaos
magic during this like they say chaos magic they
use it a bunch during the series it sounds like
that's a big part of the TV show version of this
in the books the Elder blood program is all about
defeating the white Frost and they treat it like
this existential basically world-ending threat
like basically an ice age it's going to come to
the planet and destroy it they don't actually
try to personify the white Frost as an actual
person but what happens in the books in the video
games is that we find out that aerodyn through the
wild Hunt wants to co-opt that use that power to
basically just travel between worlds and become a
conqueror of other worlds they kind of set that
up during this because at the end when Eredin
is deposited when he's stranded on this other
world he finds the skull of the other creature
that will become his helmet for the wild Hunt
and they set up the idea that they were going to
use the monoliths to try and steal resources from
other planets so it sounds like he's just going to
continue trying to do that through the wild Hunt
and by present day he finds out about Ciri's power
and her ability to open gates at will and wants to
use that so that he can just continue conquering
other worlds I think one of the reasons why they
didn't actually use Lorra Dorren and her father
Auberon during the series is because they wanted
to show you the Eredin predated them showing up
on the other world like Eredin was behind trying
to manipulate them and this otherworldly female
mage character who seemingly was manipulating
everyone that was another big addition to the
Canon like I don't remember that from the books
of the video games but like I said because
ithylene and avallac'h both talk about using the
monoliths to time travel people being lost in time
so to speak I think this otherworldly woman who's
manipulating Balor and seemingly kind of sets off
the entire plot here leading to the conjunctions
of the Spheres and what happens with Ciri later
in the timeline is actually a time traveler from
later in the timeline who's come back in time and
basically killed this other arid world like it
used to be a normal world but she turned into a
being a pure chaos magic but destroyed this other
world in the process and she is meant to represent
the actual white Frost like they're personifying
the white Frost during The Witcher series and
it'll be this woman because there's a scene when
Baylor gets his chaos magic later where you see
the world around him this arrowed world turned
to Frozen ice Frost all around him you see the
Woman's invisible whites steps walking up to him
I think that's meant to be a personification of
the actual white Frost so that at the very end of
The Witcher series like season five like however
many seasons they wind up going instead of Ciri
fighting what seems like this giant winter storm
white frost she's actually going to be fighting a
physical person and it'll be whoever this woman is
I'll explain in a second I think there are some
clues as to who it might be the white frost is
inevitable it will come to freeze the world's
one after the other eradicating all life only I
can stop the destruction but at the very end of
the series avallac'hgets the book of monoliths
and discovers that through the magic you can use
the monolith to travel across your own world and
also time travel and he travels to the past during
the events of The Witcher season one before Ciri
had met geralt this is him standing in the same
place peeking at her in the same way that geralt
was during The Witcher season one it's meant to be
a mirror for The Witcher season one like oh we've
already seen this scene during the events of this
series they portray avallac'h as being a little
more innocent more naive like at the beginning of
his journey by the time we get to present day with
Ciri and geralt he's become a more antagonistic
character he does show up during the games talking
to geralt and Ciri but he eventually pursues
Ciri towards his own ends as well so you have
to remember a big part of this is that there are
like a bunch of different forces on the show that
all want Ciri for different reasons even though
during season three we're going to meet a couple
new villains like Ciri's father Emperor Emhyr kind
of surfaces as one of the actual main villains
he's been a villain for a while now but he didn't
actually show up for real until the end of season
two he'll be a much bigger force during season
three but there are other villains on the show
Eredin and the wild Hunt are meant to be bigger
villains more antagonistic than her father but
also this mysterious woman who sounds like she's
going to be the personification of the white
Frost is an even bigger villain than aired in the
wild Hunt then we have minnie driver's character
in jaskier they said that they introduced them
because they wanted to tie the blood origin to
the main Series in a bigger way so that people who
haven't read the books or played the games kind of
understand the link between what was happening
1200 years ago and what's happened happening
in present day minnie driver isn't playing a
character from the book she's meant to be part of
an order of Seanchaí who are a real world Gaelic
order or they're based on a real world Gaelic
history that were servants of heads of lineages
that kept track of important information which she
says during the events of the series she says that
her order travels between worlds between planes of
existence collecting stories she tells jaskier to
tell the story of the Seven hoping that it will
inspire and help both geralt Ciri and the elves
of the current day of The Witcher part of the
idea and him learning this story is learning the
true origin of Aaron in the wild Hunt the threat
that he represents but also she wants to inspire
the elves of present day who are on the verge of
dying out during the events of The Witcher season
3 after he winds up learning the story she sends
him back to the battle that was happening after
the events of Witcher season 2 but before the
events of Witcher season 3 where the elves were
saving him from the temerians here's where we
get to that mysterious woman that appears as
pure chaos energy who was manipulating Baylor
seemingly setting off the the entire events of
what take place in The Witcher books like the
entire Witcher Universe this is where we get to
like a real big retcon like this isn't something
that I think is going to be from the books of the
games and I think it's them setting up their end
game ultimately for the entire series during The
Witcher season 3 they just cast an actress to play
the falca character and what they're saying is
that she's also part of Ciri's Elder blood lineage
who came from a little bit after the events that
we saw during blood origin she is a character
from the lore she's incredibly antagonistic but
what they might have done is use this time travel
twist they introduced to ithlean's prophecy and
through the monoliths and say that she was also
stranded earlier in time on this other world and
wound up destroying it turning it into the arrowed
world in her bid to become pure chaos energy like
they tried to foreshadow during the series that
Balor gaining this chaos magic it comes with a
cost like this whole world that they traveled
to this arid world didn't used to be like this
it probably used to be a very lush green world
so whoever this person is wound up destroying the
planet to become this powerful and throughout the
series Baylor keeps telling her I'll give you
anything that you want as long as you help me
gain this chaos magic power so it implies that
the woman just wants to consume other worlds and
that's why I'm saying that she's probably going to
be the personification of the white Frost that's
talked about in the books like the ultimate main
villain of all the Witcher Stories the real big
retcon being that in the books it's not actually
personified as an actual person like it's just
like this existential threat that Ciri is trying
to stop more like an actual force of nature the
showrunner did say that the wild Hunt would be one
of the biggest villains on the show in the future
but like I said that's more aired in trying to do
lower level things and it sounds like this other
mysterious woman chaos magic being is manipulating
him to do that as well the other big part of the
ending is showing you the actual conjunction
of the Spheres like the model is exploding
with all the chaos magic energy the barriers
Between Worlds planes of existence are broken
allowing the world to merge briefly while they're
merging that's how creatures humans elves all get
redistributed on all the different planets we see
the first humans get dumped on our main World they
weren't originally from this planet Eredin gets
stranded on this other world and finds the skull
of the creature that will become his helmet
for the wild Hunt the whole idea is that erden
underneath his helmet looks like this he just uses
magic in this really scary looking armor to seem
like this otherworldly creature and we also see
monsters continue to get deposited on the world
like they show the monster board the Easter egg
here is that all the monsters that are shown on
this board are monsters based on ones from the
books the showrunner said that the flying monster
they face earlier is meant to be their version
of a Hydra which is supposed to be based on the
same folklore that the books draw from the way
they Explain the origin of the witchers is also
meant to be a bit of a retcon too like they try
to introduce stuff that happens before the lore
that we already know from the books and the games
so the actual order of the witchers is meant to be
exclusively human the reason why I think they're
saying that an elf is the first proto-witcher
like why they're introducing all this is because
at this time like before the conjunction of this
years there were no humans on the planet and
they wanted to show the origin of witchers so
sort of them working in Reverse from the problem
like they can't actually show you a real witch or
like a traditional Witcher until humans wind up on
the planet and I think what they're saying is is
that the actual trial of the grasses that geralt
went through like the other traditional witchers
just wound up being an evolution of this process
like it wound up being something a little bit
different from what you saw during the series
because a big part of the actual trial of the
grasses that geralt the other witchers go through
that is eventually lost is the use of Elder blood
which Ciri has which is why during The Witcher
season two vesimir thought that he could use
Ciri's blood to recreate The Witcher potions so
that their order would not die out but the basic
idea is that after the conjunction of spheres you
have all these monsters showing up all over the
place killing people that's when the actual orders
of witchers start to rise up the more traditional
ones that you see during present day and it's
in response to all these monsters showing up all
over the place they've already released a bunch of
information about season three so I will try to do
a Witcher season 3 video in the next day or two
I'm sure there's going to be a ton of questions
just because it was a little bit confusing with
the way they explain things just in general I
didn't think that the Witcher blood origin series
was that great it played a little bit like a video
game cutscene like it worked okay as a video game
cutscene but as an actual series it felt like it
needed to be like way more episodes like there
was just too much stuff that they brushed over
and too much new stuff they introduced but didn't
fully explain everyone click here for that new
Henry Cavill Warhammer trailer video and click
here for my new Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania
trailer video thank you so much for watching happy
holidays and I'll see you guys in the next one!